so you may recall that when the fake
Duchess from Los Angeles and Braden dead
husband told Oprah that the royal family
is racist Piers Morgan called BS in them
huh that's not racist what are you even
talking about but for doing that the
media accused Piers Morgan of racism and
he was fired from his job and then when
his old friend Sharon Osborne decided to
defend Piers Morgan the media accused
Sharon Osborne of racism too
in fact Sharon Osbourne's co-host at CBS
suggested she was a bigot for asking how
exactly is Piers Morgan a racist for
pointing out that the fake Duchess was
lying so for the first time Sharon
Osborne is explaining what exactly
happened and she does it on her new show
Sharon Osborne to Helen Back which is
now on Fox Nations out on Monday and in
the show she explains how she fought the
urge
to wag a middle finger in the faces of
her CBS co-hosts watch
I was the the
disability on the news and that's
because they are wankers
we reached out to CBS for comment on
what Sharon had today and they
reiterated their statement from March
saying that they found no evidence that
she had been set up so how does this
make sense you can get ganged up on on
live television and when you go to
defend yourself against accusations you
get fired for creating a hostile work
environment this is the world we live in
today I wanted to look into the camera
and say you you
and CBS take that
Sharon Osbourne joins us tonight Sharon
thanks so much for coming on when
historians go back and do a postmortem
in our society and try to figure out how
did everyone go crazy in a four-year
period I think they're gonna take a look
at what happened I honestly do what
happened to you is one of the nuttiest
things I've ever seen you were six
degrees of separation away from the
story you just spoke up for an old
friend and you had to leave your job
have you you've thought about this I
think a lot what do you make of it
um it is the world that we're living in
and especially in film and TV where
people want to be overly overly woke so
the slightest thing it's like walking on
eggshells and there are no Second
Chances you could you could have you
know in today's world you could have put
something on your social media 10 12
years ago and people will look back and
they will fire you because you wrote it
10 12 years ago you know there are
different scenarios somebody could have
been drunk with a bunch of people you
know out of control so you may have
changed your mind by now but no even
from years ago people want to condemn
you
so I always wondered watching this story
I've never asked you about it but a lot
of the people you worked with who I
think you got along with perfectly well
really behaved in a Despicable way
toward you in a cowardly cruel way and I
wonder what was your conversation off
camera with them like did they ever
apologize to you for treating you like
that
no I had to apologize to them I mean I
must be truthful that in the first break
I was saying to one of my co-hosts why
talk to me talk to me tell me why you're
doing this tell me where this came from
why are you doing this and she turned
her back on me like this and pretended
to be talking to the um person in in the
booth and wouldn't talk to me and so I
swore at her and I did do that but you
know what I swear a lot to my friends
and if someone's a real friend she'd
been with worked with me for nearly 11
years we'd travel together dump
everything together been to my house
lots of times you know supposed to have
loved my family too and then she turns
around and stabs me in the back and you
know I do swear a lot and that's who I
am and CBS knew that before they gave me
the job and I was there nearly 11 years
so 11 years of me swearing didn't bother
them off air
it's one of the cruelest
most awful things I I I've seen and it's
a small thing but it just tells you a
lot about the mindset anyway I
appreciate uh the fact that you survived
and that you're back on TV and that you
joined us tonight
well thank you very very much and the
thing is it's not just a small thing
because nobody will touch me now because
of what happened so it's not a small
thing but I'm fine I can take care of
myself but what about the people that
can't
thousands of people that lose their jobs
that's who I worry about not me yes
people with no power sure thank you very
much
thank you so we've been trying to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight